and culture destroyed a brand new book
called resistance is futile
how the Trump hating left lost its
collective mind it's out tomorrow we're
honored to be the first stop on her book
tour and it's great to see it what did
you learn spending all this time
forensically looking at the anti-trump
left well I think your description just
there describes the nevertrump errs
beautifully with the left I think it's
more that they just they really do hate
deplorable
they hate the Walmart crowd they and
that's what they see in Trump they're
able to attack the gun culture and
Walmart's and middle class middle
Americans by attacking Trump without
getting called on it because you know
technically he's a billionaire who's
president but really at the bottom of it
they just think he's icky and so they go
on and on about this existential crisis
facing America and and Russian collusion
without allowing anyone else in their
little closed set so that even smart
people as you point out they become
crazier and crazier and they are
rewarded for being crazy as John Brennan
and clapper and Comey were I mean one
point it was the left who wanted to chop
those three up and feed them to the dogs
and all they had to do we start sending
unhinged tweets as John Brennan has and
suddenly he's a hero like I go through
in my book not only all of the lies
Brennan has told and why he was hated
and for good reason on the head of the
CIA and just constantly lying lying
lying left really hated him then as soon
as he starts sending those crazy tweets
about Trump being you know treason a
sudden history will judge you I just
have one sentence of the names he was
called after that you know one of the
most honored men MSNBC deep credibility
CNN suddenly it's a Cinderella story
that's not great welcome back can I ask
you a question that I've been thinking
about for the past year it happened I
don't know the answer so the group that
the left hates most the middle classes
you just correctly said the group that
Trump represents is also the group doing
the most poorly the middle
is dying and shrinking its life
expectancy has declined
why don't they feel sorry for the middle
class it is their hatred of Trump has
has has caused them to lose all reason I
mean it seems to me it used to be well
both political parties would claim to
care about the working man the
middle-class family both political
parties used to want to defend the
border both political parties used to
attack the concept of anger babies and
illegal aliens committing crimes and
legally aliens committing crimes but I
mean you do kind of worry Trump had this
uncanny ability to raise important
issues that Americans care about but
it's getting to the point I mean now you
know my governor says America wasn't
wasn't ever great if that's what he's
driving them - part of it is of course
the that's what their base are a large
portion of their base wants but I really
wish we could sit down liberals and and
ask them why I mean I'm I'm not a
waitress at Wendy's I'm not a Union
bookkeeper but I care about my fellow
American why don't they well it's a
great question it's an obsession of this
show and I and I honestly don't know the
answer but I do agree with you that it
does seem like Trump among other things
has totally corroded their own standards
like they will say anything when you get
peace against Trump and tell the truth
but they don't yes I mean if the
resistance were smart I think they would
read my book it gives them excellent
advice which is attack Trump on the
stuff he's actually done
don't keep as my friend Joe delayed
DeVito says it's a buffet don't keep
bringing your own food to the buffet
there's plenty they are to attack you
don't need to make things up but they
make things up and the stories get
crazier and crazier and as luck would
have it I don't have a job so I can
spend months going through Nexus I see
the complete insane contradictions of
the what you know them saying the
dossier is is you know it's proved we
know it's true because it was used to
get a FISA warrant that was used to get
a FISA warrant on on Carter page and
then
months later we find out that the
dossier was Hillary Clinton funded
research and suddenly where did you get
the idea that dossier had anything to do
with this investigation with the Warrens
on Carter page and you know I have the
quote side by side - I bet you do
because I read your column and what
people who know you on television may
not know is that you write your own
stuff and you are a brilliant writer and
I mean that I think even people who
disagree with you would agree with that
so I hope this book sells a ton of
copies it's out tomorrow resistance is
futile greatest title of a book this
year Thank You Ann Coulter great thank
you for having me on